I had a rebellious streak early it was
never it was never I wanted to hurt
somebody streak there were moments of
that but when we were poor and if I feel
like I've been figured out boy look out
I will become something completely
different so when I got up there it was
just horrendous he was like backstage
going totally totally boring
they were playing you know excerpts from
Jesus Christ Superstar like you know
crucify him crucify him crucify me
what's up believe nation it's evan my
one word is believe and i believe in you
i believe in your potential and i want
to see that thing that you've got inside
you explode out into the world to have a
big impact for you your family and the
world so to help you on your journey
today we're gonna learn from actor
producer and comedian Jim Carrey and my
take on his top ten rules of success
volume two
rule number one is my personal favorite
and I'd love to know which one you guys
like the best and as always guys as
you're watching if you hear something
that really really resonates with you
please leave it down the comments below
and put quotes around that so other
people can be inspired and when you
write it down it's much more likely to
stick for yourself as well
enjoy
was there a moment where you first sort
of realized like I want to be a
performer this is what I want this is
the thing that I want to do with my life
there was never any other choice
yeah there's never any other choice from
the time I can that I that there was
consciousness in the body I was I was
looking at a man named Percy my dad who
was the most incredible character that
you'd ever meet if you met him for five
minutes you thought you knew him for 50
years and he wrapped every one that came
into our house in stories and jokes and
they left my house always with pee
stains Percy oh man you missed your
calling Percy missed your calling like
that and you know so I became his
calling at a certain point and he was
always super behind me but from the
first time I can remember him just
lighting up the room you know and him
just like wrapping everybody in a story
or whatever and and going oh that's
that's the thing I want to do you know
that's that's what I want to be
[Music]
I was fully you know prepared to just
play out you know stand-up comedy in the
comedy clubs yeah but there's somebody
within you that constantly push the
edges of the envelope wherever you were
well or at least took advantage of the
opportunities that came around and a lot
of it has to do with you know just the
courage to jump in I mean you know to do
films that are out of your so-called
power alley
as they call it is it takes nerve you
know so I have the nerve you know and
we'll see if I have the goods but I have
the nerve and yeah I I'm just excited
really about always changing about
crossing you back and forth across the
river and throwing the hounds off the
trail I love that just whatever you
think that just when we think we've got
you we know you you're off on another
route absolutely and if I feel like I've
been figured out boy look out I will
become something completely different
you know maybe I might might not want to
become something completely different
but express something completely
different I always felt like if the
world is going crazy I'll be calm and if
and if they're calm I'll be the one
hanging off the chandelier
[Music]
at one point are not at one point
because I hear you still do you would be
in front of a mirror and just make faces
always yeah for me it was it was so much
fun to me to sit in my room and make
faces and talk to myself in different
voices and in things and they're gone
that looks like Sammy yeah it is like
Sarah you know yeah he does that you
know and that I just sit for hours doing
that and and my parents were so worried
they would you know they would say you
know my mother tried to scare me with
the spiritual thing you know it's just
like if you don't stop doing that you're
gonna see the devil know that kind of
thing and and I of course that you know
that just made me do it more I mean I
got a lot of support from my parents
that's the one thing that I always
appreciated is that they didn't tell me
I was being stupid they told me I was
being funny yeah that was the difference
when you were 15 your father took you to
a comedy club to perform yeah my mother
dresses me in a polyester suit tells me
you know this is what all the boys are
wearing and sends me down there my
father helped me write my act and and I
I went down to the comedy club and the
owner of the club had this little thing
that he liked to do where he would stand
backstage with a microphone and all
kinds of fun effects and you know heckle
new comedians and so when I got up there
it was just horrendous he was like
backstage going totally totally go de
bourree
they were playing you know excerpts from
Jesus Christ Superstar like you know
crucify him crucify him crucify that
kind of thing so you know when you go
through a few of those experiences you
kind of develop a thick skin when it
comes to being ridiculed or whatever why
didn't you give it up I couldn't I I
mean I don't have a trade
I don't really look for things and it's
the same with painting and sculpting
whatever I'll just start and I and and
it happened it happens that later on my
subconscious mind told me something just
like the scripts tell me something about
where I was at you know and so they find
me you know I and that's why I disappear
for long periods of time because people
gonna move the hill man you're supposed
to make 2.5 movies are you yeah and I
and I know but that's that's playing to
a demographic and I don't want to do
that ever
and plus when you go away a little bit
sometimes you learn a new stroke you
know it's like you cut you lop your
right arm off to learn how to write with
your left and then you sew the right arm
back on we've learned and then you go
hey you check it out you can come back
still you can do the old stuff but the
new stuff is there too
you have with you on some of you head
with you on this blurry moss who with
yes great acting code terrific
absolutely and as good as you are and
knowing you self as well as you do what
does someone like that bring to you like
the knowledge knowledge and also you
know support absolutely when you go into
new areas you know you you you you like
to be mentored in certain ways I mean
I'm not too old for a mentor and and he
certainly did I never get too old for
mentor absolutely not you know I think I
think it's you never get too old to
learn something new and when Frank came
to my house and he said he said Jim I
know you're a home run hitter but now
you have to learn a new swing yeah and
and I said you know meaning you're not
swinging for the fence perhaps in a
baseball metaphor or not necessarily
swinging doing the sacrifice fly or you
know whatever whatever you have to do
and and I was just - game I was I was
into it I love it I love I love the idea
that at my age I can learn something new
and go into a different area anything
that doesn't work out any show that I
might not get any any show that I might
do that doesn't turn out well gets
pulled off or something like that I
always think of as this is the way it
was supposed to be that's the way it was
supposed to happen because there's
something bigger down the road there's
something better down the road and that
and this is happening because I'm not
ready or you know and it's always
happened that way I mean the first time
I ever went to Yuk Yuk's when I was 15
years old I went to Church Street the
old yucky Acts it was two lanes of a
bowling alley and I went there and and I
was not good it was all right I mean I
was you were 15 I was 15 I had a white
polyester suit on my mom put on if I
went down there with that and and got up
on stage and and I was doing all right
really but the owner of the club got on
the mic backstage and started going
totally boring and all those things it
wasn't hip enough for them so so I was
pretty shattered and I didn't go back
for two years and then my father said
when I was seven
I started doing little shows here and
there again and he said why don't you go
back to your kicks I said no way I don't
want to go back there
and he said well you really you know you
should get over it I mean if you if
you're gonna gonna go into the business
and you want to do it seriously you
can't have those barriers you know and
and I went back and I did great and I
became a regular and a headliner and and
it built from there and then when I went
down to Los Angeles the same thing
happened I went to the comedy star I did
all right but not good enough to become
a regular and I become totally
discouraged the comedy star I came back
to Toronto like everybody who doesn't do
well down there comes back on hate Los
Angeles it's such a crummy place no
really
you can't raise kids there and all that
stuff and Comedy Store is a rat race
it's a rat race but then two years later
again my father he says to me well you
should try and get into the comedy store
and and my manager set up a showcase
there like I went in and I did well and
became a regular there and everything
has happened from there since it's just
it's been incredible and it always goes
in stages like that so I I accept the
fact that I fail you know because I know
that it's that's the way it's supposed
to be you know what the core be willing
to grab me a short bathroom break can't
it wait yes it can I had a rebellious
streak early it was never it was never I
wanted to hurt somebody streak there
were moments of that but when we were
poor but but there was mostly a I I want
to challenge your beliefs I want to
challenge the the the properness of this
occasion or whatever it is and throw it
on its head in a way that you can accept
and and and love and it'll free you so
I've been in the business of freeing
people from concern I call it the Church
of FFC freedom from concern you know and
that's been my ministry my whole life
okay let's settle this the old-fashioned
way I sit down with with friends of mine
who were in the in the acting profession
and
and they say you know these are really
good actors and they say man no one's
really getting the chance to do what
you're getting to do yeah you know I
mean this is a it's quite an arc at the
time and I'm again I feel so lucky to
have that
but you had to bring something otherwise
they would not continue to give you the
chance and you obviously recognize that
you have to allow yourself to be seen
that's the risk the risk is especially
for somebody who's comedic yeah who has
that that weapon at his disposal just to
go off a little rift yeah yeah to to
risk being seen is the toughest thing in
the world we're all very shy people you
know people who do comedy were shy and
the emotion is right there on the
surface if you pricked me with a pin I
would fly around the room you know so
that's the risk is that you are showing
them yourself you're your true authentic
self and the chances of being rejected
are much more important you know much
more terrifying all right just give me a
chance
silliness have been with Jim Carrey
since he was a baby born with a crooked
hat his face has never failed to get a
laugh at family parties or at school
where he says being the class clown
helped him to make friends but Jim
dropped out of school in grade 9 to mold
his act two years later his first TV
appearance the impressions were there
but the nuances weren't thank you very
much
my name is Jimmy Chiara and I am the
president of the United States of
America thank you
think about much though the nuances are
here now they did not come easily so now
it used to be Jim struggles trying to
perfect his impressions he usually
performed at a popular comedy club in
Toronto that's a fact
I used to drive like 50 miles back and
forth from Jackson's point every every
second night or every every night to do
a set at Yuk Yuk's for free no pay oh
not even the gas stub or anything
nothing I used to do that did that for
the longest time and this kept working
and tells people started to take notice
you know and and the rest was history
wild outside there what's going on hold
you know when you come in this theater
yeah the paparazzi you're a beginner is
that right well unbelievable what are
they what are they doing well they're
taking your picture but but it's like
you know they're probably selling it the
Blue Boy magazine or something but you
know just it's just wow they did they
just change so quickly I have one minute
they love you the next minute it's like
you know you're scum you know so you
walk away right it's like Jim hey good
to see ya you're looking great tonight
give me a smile come on Jim Jim
three walls man can stand here all night
Schwarzenegger let's draw him like
coming to the city for the holidays I
really do it's a good place to be in the
holidays absolutely fantastic even the
drunks are dressed up you know season
they're into it they're happy
yeah it's everyone all this place I mean
the the festivity of this of this hall
just like Santa's workshop samay zhing
you know I don't actually it's funny
thing I don't really feel like I'm like
I'm quite right with that I feel kind of
dressed up and I but I don't feel
festive enough oh no no you're fine I
just oh well I think you lack it says
Christmas yeah can I just can I just
what he's talking about
now here
[Applause]
[Applause]
Wow I feel good now
better to give sir that's right it's
better to give
that's the real holiday spirit right
there you're just getting that right up
it's a little it's just a little damp
it's nothing bad bad no he's been
running around in it for sure sorry to
inconvenience he's a plant anyway so now
let's do a little Matthew McConaughey
because here before Matt Damon is the
only one I knew we could come close on a
Matthew McConaughey and then come real
close with the microphones all right is
there a secret is there yet to do out oh
no it's real sample day all I got to do
is let go of the illusion that I exist
drive around on my Lincoln
we're all in this booger
[Applause]
I'm fine Matthew it makes me feel safe
Dave it's not even a booger anymore yeah
that's it's more of an anchor uh-huh
it's party time
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Ivan on my team
asked me to if there's someone you like
me to cover in a future top ten check
out the link in the description and go
and cast your vote I'd also love to know
what did you learn from this video what
lesson really hit home the hardest what
are you going to immediately apply
somehow to your life or to your business
leave it down the comments below I'm
really curious to find out I also want
to give a quick shout out to Tim
Schmoyer Tim thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book your one
word and posting the picture online as
well as thanking you for being one of
the blurbs on the back of my book I
really appreciate the support man and
I'm so glad that you enjoyed the book
thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love I'll see you soon
Jim I wanted to ask you some years ago
you wrote yourself a check yes I did I
guess it's like six seven years ago now
I wrote a check out to myself for 10
million dollars for acting services
rendered and in 19 by Thanksgiving 1995
and I put it in my wallet and I carried
it for that many years and and what
happened was basically a few months ago
we did the deal for them and asked for
10 million dollars ten million dollars
payment for doing the mask right payment
for doing the mask too and and so it's
very surreal for me it's it's it's
strange and I used to go up to
Mulholland Drive every night sit on the
side of the road look out at the lights
and and go you know I'm a popular actor
I'm uh you know every every director
wants to work with me and I used to like
open my arms and imagine things you know
things that I wanted to come in my way
and stuff in and what I would do it was
a way of dealing with you know being
completely out of work I would stay up
there until I actually believed that I
had all these things and then I would
drive down the mountain feeling like the
biggest star in Hollywood like I was
working all the time like like the best
people wanted to work with me and I had
my thing in my pocket my little check in
my pocket you saw you turn to film then
and then you you made it and film you at
that extraordinary year in 1994 mmm yeah
there's all the way along I mean the
projects you take I mean The Truman Show
was a was a another moment where you
know I had to kind of deal with well
you're not allowed to do that
you know you've presented yourself one
way and you know it's it's a tough thing
to convince people that there's
something more or that they might want
to see something different but I've
always believed all the way along I
believed that that it was about a spark
right it was about who you are as a
person it's about your soul yeah it's
about not necessary I mean you do what
you do so well but there is something
about you that that is attractive to
people in a way that they
to sit and watch you for an hour and and
and listen to you and list your insights
but it's about you and who you are I
want to talk to Bill Cosby at a time and
he said we were talking about what
something I wasn't doing that I didn't
enjoy doing and he said change because
in the end it's about you
what is it worth what is it worth it and
that's that's what I've come to so many
times in my career in my life is that
I've I've said the safe road is is is
gonna pay off there are there are many
payoffs to it but I can't be there and
and and have my soul be on a completely
different track I I just it's always
worth losing to me it's always worth
risking and if if if this other side of
me is not a popular one in the in the
scheme of things as far as movie tickets
go then you know what I'll find a way to
sneak it in there out I'll make a plan I
will I will show myself you know I will
find a way and even if even if I'm not
as popular I I will live in that area I
will I will expand myself Jack Nicholson
doing a job
[Music]
Clint Eastwood
[Music]
[Music]
say
you fight like a man 20 people you they
were exactly the same everyone
[Music]
you guys just be nice to you the gun
doesn't know just clap
twenties to it
[Music]
Michael Landon he would want me to do it
shoutout
finding a newborn colt
but not least James Dean keep in mind
this is the last impression so please
applaud accordingly
[Music]
he's melting at tomax now
Christine
[Music]
only the one one supermodels one long
media the most important work ever if
you had to think of one word that's most
important to you that sums you Apple so
it would be like a little beacon pay
believe nation if you want to know what
the most important one word is for Tony
Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey
will.i.am and Howard Schultz I have a
very special secret video for you check
the description for details
[Music]